[Music]
season 8 is coming
HBO dropped the first big trailer for
the new and final season of Game of
Thrones and while it may only be two
minutes long there's a lot going on that
you might have missed here's a closer
look at what you can expect to see on
April 14th the season premiere will take
place at Winterfell
with Danny and John arriving with the
unsullied in a scene meant to mirror
season 1 episode 1 and the Baratheon
arrival the wildlings and small folk are
watching from the sidelines the last
time we saw them they were helping the
Nights Watch man the wall at east watch
the little boy watching mirrors brand
from season 1 jon is also standing at
the weirwood tree ned was there in
season 1 episode 1 talking to Catelyn
the weirwood tree is also where Jon made
his Night's Watch vows in season 1 and
this scene with Dany and Jon mirrors the
conversation Robert and Ned had in front
of Leanna script much of the trailer
shows what appears to be a major battle
with the White Walkers it opens with
Arya running through Winterfell she says
I know death he has many faces a
reference to the many-faced God whom
she's been training with throughout the
series the right side of her face is
bloodied as well as her chest so she
appears to be wounded and is running
from someone or some thing which we can
assume to be the whites or the White
Walkers of course the blood may not be
her own since she gets splattered here
since we know the night king can raise
the dead
will he raise the dead Starks to help
battle the live ones
what else could spark such fear in Arya
who rarely ever gets scared war cries
and look forward to seeing this one
she's holding a new dagger that appears
to be made of dragonglass in this shot
we see a very frightened Very's hiding
in the Winterfell crypts we know it's
the crypts since there is a stark statue
in the back next to a direwolf also in
the background is Gilly with her baby
this scene is likely a reference to the
helms deep battle from the Lord of the
Rings the two towers
we're women and children hid inside
while the battle raged on outside
meanwhile Sam is seen here talking to
bran
Sam will likely be the one to tell John
about his true parentage the last time
we saw your on Greyjoy
he was on his way to Essos at Searcy's
command to fetch the golden company my
hand kybun is made of overtures to the
golden company and Essos the golden
company is a group of mercenaries that
have been mentioned multiple times
throughout the series here we see the
golden company aboard the Greyjoy fleet
led by this man
Harry Strickland played by actor Mark
Whisman some of the crew is also
carrying barrels could these be filled
with wild fire which the Lannisters have
used in the past to take out their
enemies next we have a quick shot of two
men we assumed had died beric Dondarrion
and tormund Giantsbane the last time we
saw them they were atop the wall moments
before the night King burned it down
with a white Walker version of the
Syrian a line in the script from this
episode proved they got out alive but we
didn't actually see them until now here
Searcy is flanked by the mountain now a
zombie and master Qyburn who reanimated
him the three appear to be at King's
Landing looking over Blackwater Bay
Searcy could be smiling at the arrival
of Euron and the golden company but
there's a chance he may try to betray
her the two remaining dragons ragel and
drogon arrive at Winterfell and we see
both Sansa's and Arya's reaction to
seeing them for the first time in one
shot the dragons are finishing a recent
meal we know that because the snow is
melted and there's a pile of bones and
John and Danny approached them with
their heads down it looks like they're
about to mount them Jon on regel and
Danny on drogon since ragle was named
after Rhaegar Targaryen John's father
the last time we saw Gendry the last
remaining Baratheon he was at East Watch
after sprinting back from the wall here
he is once again possibly at Winterfell
helping to forge weapons out of
dragonglass
to fight the White Walkers
since he's a Baratheon will he
ultimately sit on the Iron Throne
speaking of weapons in season 7 Samwell
stole his father's sword cold hot bang
which is made of Valyrian steel in the
trailer it looks like he has given this
sword to Jorah Masson day and grey worm
are seen kissing as he heads off to
battle with the unsullied will this be
the last time they see each other
Brienne and Podrick are also at
Winterfell and this scene might show her
killing a white clearly something has
caught fire during the battle Jaime is
also on the Winterfell rooftops
screaming run Arya makes it up there and
is fighting White's with a spear and the
Hound who is deathly afraid of fire also
appears amongst the flames while sitting
on the Iron Throne
Searcy is speaking with two people one
of whom appears to be yyur on the
trailer also hints at some news about
Searcy in season 7 she claimed to be
pregnant but he or she is taking a sip
of wine is she no longer pregnant or was
she never pregnant to begin with she
also likes to enjoy a glass of wine
after destroying her enemies so someone
else may have just met their doom when
we see Jon run into battle there's a
quick shot of some horses galloping but
if you look closely there's also a set
of white paws so it looks like we may
see Jon's direwolf ghost once again
noticeably absent from this trailer
Melisandre where is she and can we
expect to see her in season 8 we'll have
to wait until April 14th to know
anything for sure did you spot anything
that we didn't let us know in the
comments